[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator tv
recorded on thursday april the 1st this
week we look at the latest covet data
and ask where that leaves vaccine
passports
and foreign travel bans i'll also be
speaking to mercy
muraki one of the commissioners for this
week's landmark report on racism
in britain and to activist fayyas
magal about what islam really says about
portrayals
of the prophet muhammed and at the end
of this show
another big question what should the
west do about
china all that's to come in the next
hour of top analysis and debate
now if you enjoy what we do here on
spectator tv why not take out a
subscription to the spectator magazine
it's the fastest growing current affairs
publication
in europe and within its pages and on
our website you can read all your
favorite
spectator tv contributors but even throw
in a bottle of free
spectator gin if you sign up at
spectator dot co
dot uk slash tv offer
or just google spectator gin that's a
subscription
of 12 issues for just 12 pounds plus a
free bottle
of gin worth 30 pounds so do the maths
or if you're american do the math it's a
no-brainer either way
and is a very very special thanks to
charles stanley for their continued
support of the week in 60 minutes
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms
one of the oldest companies on the
london stock exchange
we're delighted to be partners with them
the success of the british vaccine
rollout has put pressure on the johnson
government
to end lockdown restrictions more
quickly than it's planning
compared with italy where there's a new
lockdown france
where a new lockdown begins this weekend
and germany
where new restrictions have been
introduced it's a nice problem for the
uk government
to have but so far it's sticking to a
very
cautious re-emergence from lockdown
much to the chagrin of some of its
supporters
in a moment i'll be joined by the
spectators editor fraser nelson
and its political editor james forsythe
but first
let's have a look at the latest data
kate andrews is our economics
correspondent
and editor of the daily lunchtime
briefing
it's the only roundup email that you
need
for the latest cover news kate
over to you thanks andrew the cover data
continues to look very positive
with infections admissions to hospital
and emissions into intensive care
all down 90 since the peak of this wave
of the virus and deaths are down nearly
95
and for the second week in a row as you
can see from this first slide
deaths have fallen below their five year
average in the latest week ending the
19th of march there were just over
10 300 registered deaths in england and
wales
down 8 percent on the average now
some of this data is a result from
people staying inside staying at home
but we're definitely seeing the vaccine
factor shining through now
thanks to the uk's hugely successful
rollout it's now estimated by the office
for national statistics
that in the four weeks leading up to the
14th of march that's the latest data set
we have
that one in two people in england wales
and northern ireland have antibodies
two and five people in scotland are
around 40 percent of people
now some of that will be down to
infection and building up antibodies
from having the virus
but as you can see these numbers are
moving up very quickly
and for infection rates to be plummeting
while antibody rates are rising that is
clearly the result of a working vaccine
and the uk continues to storm ahead in
the vaccine race still ranking in the
top five countries
for rate of doses administered compared
to the population size
now unfortunately there has been a bit
of a setback and we're expecting a slow
down this month
as millions of doses of oxford
astrazeneca are being held up
in india and this means that the uk's
policy
of prioritizing first doses is going to
pivot to prioritizing
second doses as you can see here that
shift has already started
and we should expect to see that blue
line noting second doses second jabs
going up for some time even outpacing
first doses
now there are pros and cons to this
obviously the change in tactic that we
have fewer
doses available than hoped is not great
and given that there's early evidence
showing that the vaccine does reduce
transmission of the virus
that really bolsters the uk's original
strategy of just getting out as many
first doses as possible
that is disappointing as well but that
said these second doses are giving that
extra boost that maximum coverage to
those who are elderly and most
vulnerable
so that is positive and the other good
news is that the uk 17 million doses of
the moderna vaccine
are expected to come online in the
coming weeks and those are being
earmarked for the under 50 so we can get
those
first doses up again and in this last
slide you can see here our vaccine
progress the progress for getting the
elderly and vulnerable in society
vaccinated is still really impressive
the spectator's data tracker shows the
government is on target to offer this
vaccine
the first dose anyway to the top nine
priority groups by the 15th of april
that was the deadline that the
government gave itself they are on track
to do so
in fact our data tracker shows that it
might be slightly early but
given the slow slow down in doses we'll
see where we end up
overall the news is very positive and
the prime minister promised data not
dates
if we look at the data section we only
have good news at the moment to share
and there's a question mark as to
whether or not his comments about
prioritizing data
over dates might come back to haunt him
as there's no indication that he'll be
speeding up
this road map but given that mps have
renewed the coronavirus act
it doesn't seem like there's a huge
amount of pressure on him to do so
back over to you andrew thanks kate and
we'll come on to uh
what the government's reaction to all
this good news is and these charts are
certainly
probably the most encouraging charts
we've seen since this pandemic started
just over a year ago there is i have to
report rather sadly a lot of
sneering uh among journalists and the
political elite not among ordinary
people but among
some journalists in the political elite
in europe that uh
yeah well you brits think you've done
well
but you've only been doing first doses
and you are
you won't even have enough vaccine now
to do second doses
is there any truth in that is there any
evidence that that's the case
so first of all the government has
indicated that they are not worried
about dishing out second doses they are
confident that they have enough jobs to
secure second doses in the appropriate
timeline
that they've laid out so people if
they've had their first dose shouldn't
be worried about that
all indication from government is that
they're on track to get
their second dose and it is frustrating
to hear that kind of language to be
disparaging towards getting
first doses into arms because in reality
that first dose is giving you the
majority of the coverage
it's really important you get your
second dose that tops you up even more
it gives you the maximum coverage that
you can get from this vaccine
very important but getting that first
dose does provide after a few weeks once
it's
kicked in quite a lot of protection and
as mentioned in the slideshow the early
evidence is that
these vaccines are also reducing
transmission of the virus
so getting that first dose isn't just
protecting yourself it's also helping to
protect
those around you so so those who try to
knock the uk success by pointing to
first doses i think look a bit silly
the fact that we have over half of
adults in the uk
having at least their first job is
something to be extremely proud of all
right kate thanks for that stick with us
uh frieza's joining us now fraser um
why is the government so worried
about relaxing travel bans well
it's not just kingdom it's extending
them i mean the fact that it's now
illegal to leave the country
is really it's quite a new development
and you do wonder why if
we've made such progress with vaccines
surely the whole point of this is that
we don't need to be afraid
of the virus as we once were but what
they're worried about
is the potential emergence of the new
strain of covert which might
escape the vaccine now this is only
hypothetical they've been something like
20 000 mutations of um coronavirus
as a rna virus this is what it does it
mutates it comes in many forms
but there's been some suggestion that
the south african variant
might be less effective with against the
astrazeneca
vaccine now there's no evidence at all
that anybody's being reinfected
in south africa in fact the database is
counting re-infections globally
can find fewer than a hundred of them
out of tens of
hundreds of millions of people who've
been infected with the virus
but the prospect the theory but there
might
be a mutation out there which might come
back to britain that might put us back
to square one
is enough for the government to think
okay we're going to adopt the
precautionary principle
a safety first mechanism so until we can
be sure
that the variant will not escape the
astrazeneca vaccines by the way the
israelis have said there's no variant
which escapes the pfizer vaccines but
we're
mainly rolling out the astral ones then
the british approach
is to be very cautious on summer
holidays not let anyone leave the
country without
a reasonable excuse and to certainly be
very cautious about anybody coming in
james the government talking as frieza
says about even toughening up the
already tough travel bans
and or vaccine passports something it
seemed to be against not long ago but
now talking of that too
i don't understand why you would talk
about two i mean if you've
if you haven't got vaccine passports i
can understand where you why
you might want a tough travel ban uh but
if you've got vaccine passports
why do you need a travel ban as well uh
andrew i think
as fraser says the worry is about a
vaccine of aiding variant
they think that is most likely to occur
in a country where
covert is in high circulation where
there are lots of
cases and and that is why i think they
are thinking these restrictions i think
when it comes
we'll get some more details uh next week
of what they're thinking on travel
but i think what it will mean is that
you know going to countries with low
levels of covered and
high levels of vaccination will be
allowed it will be countries that have
low uh either high levels of covert or
low levels of vaccination that will be
kind of
uh on the kind of red list um so i think
for example you know if you were
planning to go to tel aviv for your
summer holiday i think you're
you're pretty certain to be able to go i
think what is much
less certain are some of the popular
european hot spots
unless you see a big increase in the
pace of the european rollout
but if you made a condition of coming to
britain that
you had to have a vaccine possible it
showed that you had been vaccinated
perhaps with both
doses and that you had had a test
in the previous 72 hours before landing
wouldn't that be job done if you had
both these things yeah i mean in terms
of people coming back into the country i
think what
i guess really said what their worry is
is
a strain emerging that evades or
all that the uh vaccines that the uk is
using is
less effective against um they often
talk about
you know that even once you vaccinated
the population
uh you have a certain number of still
have a certain number of vulnerable
people who if they all
ended up in hospital you would put your
health system under pressure i think
that their concern is
as fraser says variant against which the
vaccine is not so effective
i can understand fraser why the
government is cautious in a way it
basically doesn't want to blow it
i mean we've made so much progress in
the
early months of this year after a pretty
dismal start
that caution is is understandable even
if it may not
always be right is there any sign of the
government changing tack here is there
any sign is the kind of information
kate was giving it giving us continues
to grow
that it will in some way have second
thoughts even just at the margin
i'm afraid not so there's a paradox here
but the more progress the government
makes and the vaccine roll out the lower
the virus levels are forced back the
more nervous the government
is it's almost as if it wants to make us
kind of born again
australia using our island status to to
and
isolate us from the rest of the world
and the strange thing is that the the um
the precautionary principle
is a very interesting political
development because it completely
transforms the relationship
between the state and the individual i
mean back a couple of years ago
if the government wanted to restrict
your liberty to stop you leaving the
country
it would have to prove there is a very
good reason a very good threat
but it could stop you moving about in
this way
but now this has been flipped into
reverse there is a theoretical
prospect of a vaccine evading variant
and until it can be proved that this
doesn't exist nobody leaves
the country so this takes us into the um
incredible
position i remember a few years ago my
mother-in-law who fled the soviets back
in the 60s
was explaining to my kids how she did it
her great escape
that she needed an exit visa and they
were just amazed to hear this how could
you have an exit visa needed to leave
a country um i would never have thought
that we'd be back here in 2021
introducing a system of exit visas
without a very good reason
and i'm afraid to say at the moment
there is not a very good reason there is
a reason to be fearful
but i'll tell you what's at the back of
their minds andrew there's one country
that has made
even more progress than us on vaccines
well a few countries but one in
particular
we saw it at the start of the slides
kate showed us
earlier on that's chile chile has
vaccinated more people as a portion of
the population than the uk
but when the third wave came along chile
has found itself
completely overwhelmed yet again chris
whittie spoke about
how in britain if the third wave would
come it would meet a wall
of vaccinated people well in chile there
is a wall of vaccinated people but the
cobit wave seems to have crushed that
wall pretty quickly
so the nightmare scenario the government
is that right now
those favorable graphs that that and
kate has showed us
will completely change due to a new
threat because one thing we do know
about covet is that it surprises us
all the time and as being fearful of a
new surprise
that means we're pretty unlikely to be
able to move as we would like this
summer
and bizarrely this summer we'll be
considerably less free to move
than we were last summer in spite of all
the progress
on vaccines and then taming the virus
but frasier does the government have a
full picture of what's been going on in
chile i mean presumably those who have
been vaccinated are not getting covert
um and that a lot of the new this new
third wave is among younger people who
although they may catch it are very
unlikely to die or even be hospitalized
by it
yes that's right and also you can look
at the sort of vaccines which they've
had
in chile are they as good as the
astrozenica vaccines and the pfizer
vaccines which
we've had in in this country but you
know right now the government doesn't
it doesn't take much encouragement to
hoist the drawbridge
back up all it needs the potential risk
to say
for example ah look at chile they've
been vaccinated still got a problem so
maybe we have a problem
often the rationale doesn't go much
beyond that when you're talking to the
people the policy makers people who are
deciding the uk policy
they will always say what about this
what about that unless you can prove
that the threats they're talking about
don't exist they think well
let's be cautious and let's let nobody
leave and nobody come in
james fraser talking there about how the
government is even doesn't
want us to leave the country
but if you are vaccinated particularly
if you've had both
doses why would it matter if we left the
country
uh the fear is that let's imagine that
you'd be vaccinated with both doses you
leave the country and you encounter
uh the the now infamous vaccine invading
variant you would then bring that back
and you could then spread this new
version of covid
around the country and it was and
because there would be
no non-pharmaceutical interventions in
place to use the lingo so there would be
no
bars on social distancing no limits on
gathering size and the like
that could then spread very quickly
around the uk that that is what their
concern is
what james if you added in the rule that
uh
to get back into the country i'm
speaking as a british if you're a
british citizen or
resident in the united kingdom to get
back into the country in addition to the
fact that you're in vaccinated
you have to show a test within
72 hours of you landing back in the
country
yeah i look i i think you i think you
could argue with that that would be
i mean you could argue that would be a
sensible precaution that should
allow them to loosen up the rules i
think that as fraser said though
there's been a mindset shift in
government we had a kind of generation
of politicians
who were used to the worst case scenario
not happening you know think over
the millennium bug birth blue tony blair
wrote about in his
um autobiography about how there was a
whole phd thesis to be written on the
pandemics
that never happened you've now got a set
of politicians and officials
who've seen the reasonable worst case
scenario
come true and i think that is making
them extremely cautious
about making these decisions i think i
mean their view of risk
is very different from how it was uh 18
months ago
kate we understand michael gove is
looking doing reviews of a lot of what
we've
been discussing about how quickly do we
get out of lockdown what should the
steps be in all the rest of it
should there be any changes to the the
timeline that we already have
do we know where we are with the goal of
reviews yet
no we're going to find out a lot more
next week there are four crucial reviews
to look to one around social distancing
one around foreign travel
one around working from home policy and
one around vaccine passports
uh domestic vaccine passports now the
one that everyone's looking to at the
moment is that last one because
that information is expected very soon
and there's rumors that they're looking
at using
that nhs app that people downloaded to
track and trace whether or not they had
been in contact
with somebody else who had coven 19
potentially turning that in
to some kind of vaccine certificate or
negative
cova test certificate now unlike foreign
travel for better for worse wherever you
fall into that category there does seem
to be
pretty broad consensus between the
political parties that that was the
right area to crack down on
when it comes to domestic vaccine
passports it looks like we're going to
see much more of a battle
you have kiyostama leader of the labor
party this morning telling
the daily telegraph that he thinks that
such a concept would be unbritish
now he notably gave himself a lot of
wiggle room to determine what he might
support or what he might not support but
there is push back there
um the leader of the liberal democrats
told katie balls in this week's magazine
as well
that he would be opposing vaccine
passports so the government's going to
get a lot more
pushback and i think the sense is if you
tell people
correctly that vaccines work and if you
have a british public that is
overwhelmingly happy to take that
vaccine it does seem very strange to
start bringing in
systems and mechanisms that would
require you to update your
health status negative tests vaccines to
an app to have to show that
when you're going about day-to-day
activity whether that be going to a
supermarket getting on a bus
going to the pub um i think the question
mark is probably around whether or not
all of these parties would
unite together to say if there's a mass
event a big event thousands of people
perhaps you have to show something
but the government probably for one of
the first times in this crisis
is going to be facing real pushback if
michael gove
tries to push to use this app in some
way to turn into a
a vaccine certificate and as well not
just from the principal vaccine
certificates but also
what we were told about this app and we
we were sold this app we were told to
download
it because it was always going to be
private information only you
were going to see what was on that app
if the idea is you're now flashing that
app
to landlords and pub owners and the rest
of it it's a totally different ball game
okay kate uh thank you for that we'll
let you go now
uh james and fraser are staying with us
and just before i
move on fraser i was interested that you
you mentioned how the
precautionary principle uh supercaution
uh had come back to the center of
government policy and what we were
talking about
didn't mr johnson and those around him
in the brexit campaign
say that one reason we should leave the
european union
was to get away from the eu's obsession
with the precautionary principle
yes this is exactly the irony they were
talking a lot about this because the
precautionary principle is used a lot
in eu law it basically means you can
justify all kinds of
costs and take all kinds of relative
draconian measures
and against something which may or may
not happen so you managed to
avoid the normal conversations about
well how likely is this risk
how much um money are we likely to spare
how much liberty will we
give up in order to stop this risk
happening so rather than the trade-off
the precautionary principle says
something else okay
this might happen small risk we're not
going to quantify that risk
but let's do x y and z to stop it
happening now boris johnson quite
rightly in my view said look
this really mitigates against
risk-taking innovation
it constrains liberty we need to get out
of this and have a britain
which is able to respond and take
advantage of its own
the fortunes which is able to create for
itself well subsequently he was as good
as a word on vaccines the uk government
can
went for a completely different way than
the eu sourced its vaccines
and created a whole lot of potential to
think okay
now that we've got this now that we've
protected those who are likely to die
and from the virus we can now go our own
way we can open up our economy we can
take a more globally minded view of the
world
and restore britain's reputation and
practical
identity as an international hub brits
are more likely to travel by air
than the con people of any other country
in the world
but instead of that they've once right
behind the precautionary
principle and have allowed it to dictate
the approach out of the pandemic so
right now make no mistake
and if boris johnson were feeling a bit
more self-confident
of the self-confidence which he claims
drove him through the brexit situation
then we would be opening up a lot more
we wouldn't we would be saying
well let why can't we let people who've
been vaccinated or
who'd be got a negative test come to
britain because reasonably we don't need
to fear them
but instead the mindset of the
government has shifted and it shifted in
a rather illiberal way
and what i think we can see now is the
emergence of illiberal
conservatism ironically coming under a
self-professed
liberal prime minister but he looks at
the opinion polls
and he looks at people asked do you want
borders to be closed if opinion pools
say yes
he thinks there's a new kind of buzz a
new kind of mood a new kind of
illiberalism in the country
and as the old saying goes he thinks i
am the leader i must follow him
okay president we'll follow on to our
next story the other big story of this
week
is the landmark report from the
government's commission on race and
ethnic disparities it's caused
quite a a row among those who thought
they controlled the agenda when it came
to
racism and racial and ethnic disparities
fraser let me
just come to you to just give us the
context of how this report has come
about
well for a long time now the
government's been trying to
look at british race relations and all
of its
dimensions and to try to break away from
importing a kind of american narrative
onto a country which simply doesn't
fit it so if you look in britain we're a
country where
black africans and indians tend to do
better
not just than whites than by
bangladeshis
and black caribbean groups so there are
huge and indefensible
differences in attainment between the
ethnicities but it's not as simple as
black versus white it's not white versus
bane
even the label being lumps together
people of all sorts of ethnicities with
very divergent groups
now if you really want to tackle the
difference here the government argued
you need to
to get rid of this reductive um identity
politics
and have a look at here what can we
learn so
it brought together this visual
commission and commission
appointed by the government but
independently um
an independent report to completely turn
on the head
the narrative of the race relations
industry involving people who hadn't
been
involved in this campaigning industry to
point out that the black lives matter
protests
have and according to opinion polls most
people think they've worsened race
relations
rather than made things closer so to
have a look at the evidence 285 pages of
evidence
and ask instead what can we learn from
it it's upset a lot of people who had
previously thought that they were
setting
the race relations agenda but there's a
whole bunch of new voices now but this
government wants to listen to
and these new voices through this
commission have a very different story
to tell
about the truth and the challenges of
race relations in britain today
james is the government aware of the
what it's up against here i mean it's
it's come out with a report which in its
essence
challenges many of the nostrums of
identity politics
but we now live in an age in which
identity politics is on the rise and for
many people is the main form of
discourse
does it realize the the challenge that
it's got
yeah i think if you look at the fact
that they appointed tony sewell to
to chair this commission i mean that
showed that they they were prepared to
take on
some of these arguments and i think it i
think it is a significant political
moment because
uh i think there has been an all there
has been an odd situation where
the where some of the arguments about
race have kind of
failed to acknowledge the fact that
while there's undoubtedly still work to
do
things have got massively better in this
country
in the last 50 years in the last 30
years i'd argue even the last five years
and i think that that is what this
report is challenging i think
one of the crucial points it makes is
that this this division of the
population
to white and bame was i think very
unhelpful because i mean i mean
i think as as uh the leader in this
week's magazine says you know
it disguised all sorts of differences
within these groups and and i think
created a kind of quite unhealthy sense
of uh of division and i think what
hopefully what you can begin to get to
now
is a more nuanced understanding of
the different challenges facing
different groups
and that and that it's not an a kind of
a simple
binary approach is not going to work
well it didn't seem that the government
or the government report has finally
caught up with thomas sue
who wrote all about this almost 40 years
ago
in his masterpiece book ethnic america
but
there we go better late than never i
suppose and we're joined by
one of the commissioners who authored
the report must say
moroccan is a columnist a senior
researcher at the center for social
justice welcome to spectator tv
let me just go through some of the
things that i think the report says
and you can mark my card one of the
conclusions would seem to be that when
we look at disparities
in performance between various ethnic
groups
but family structure and social class
often have a bigger impact than race
is that correct yes you see this
uh thank you for having me on uh before
i uh begin uh
you see this in a lot of the areas we
looked at we looked at education
crime and policing health and
employment and enterprise and just to
take
education as an example uh socio
we commissioned a bespoke study from the
university of oxford and actually
it clearly showed that socioeconomic
differences
are the key drivers of um sort of
academic performance across different
ethnic groups
but even then it's completely uh
complicated as well because what you see
is ethnic minority children actually
at the same social class even go on to
outperform
um their white counterparts in many
instances and often
the disparities in family structures
between the different ethnic groups are
absolutely
uh staggering but if you look at the
group that has the highest level of
lone parenthood this is caribbean kids
we're talking six
in ten caribbean kids growing up in lone
parent
um households and we know that uh
working class uh households are also
more likely to be
a lone parent households than middle
class households so you can
very much begin to map the uh ethnic
differences in outcomes uh
with the um with these other factors
such as socioeconomic
and family structures well messy that
brings me to the next question i wanted
to ask because i think the report
gives the data that shows that that the
that among all the ethnic groups that
make up uh britain and
there are many of them sometimes you
kind of lump them as if they're an
undifferentiated mass but actually
there's incredible diversity among all
the ethnic uh
groups and that the only ethnic
group every other every ethnic group
performs better than whites
bar black caribbean pupils
is that correct yes that's uh
correct andrew and um as i say this is
why we simply can't
um make this a bone versus white issue
and actually beyond that
you you get um people saying you know
black exclusions for
instance black outcomes you can't even
do that because actually what we see is
african children outperform white kids
outperform
you know uh the the kind of average and
black caribbean kids are one of the
worst performing so even once you start
saying well there must be racism towards
black kids because
exclusions you know african kids are not
no more likely to be excluded
from school than their white british
counterparts again it's the black
caribbean kids that see these high
levels of exclusions and then that
then you have to ask yourself hang on a
second is this
institutional racism blanket explanation
adequate or is there
other things going on that mean even if
you're black
your outcomes are likely to be different
depending on whether you're
an african immigrant or you know a third
generation black caribbean child
and i was reading that the the pay gap
between ethnic groups the average among
ethnic groups
and the average in the white population
the pay gap is down
now to 2.3 percent and something that i
thought
gave great hope for the future was that
your
report says it's now negligible
for people under 30. yes that's right so
uh the ethnic pay gap and this is the
between white british majority
and ethnic minorities is down to two
point three percent which is the lowest
level
you know in a decade so again you see
that you know upwards trajectory i know
there are
a lot of people in the race lobby who
don't want to accept at all that there
might have been any progress over the
last you know
couple of decades but you know the
data's very clear on this and as you say
the um under 30s don't see any you know
statistically significant
wage gaps between them so again you know
there's uh this idea that we haven't
progressed or that
um we're kind of uh cherry-picking data
to show
where there might be bits of progress
and hiding the other data it's not true
because this is you know
official statistics these are national
statistics and
um you know if they want to argue with
that they they shouldn't be arguing with
us quite frankly they should be arguing
with the
you know the statisticians who produce
these robust
uh data sets now the report does not say
there's no racism in britain that would
be absurd we still see
many individual examples of it or racist
attitudes and
and so on that that cannot be just uh
hidden away you see it particularly in
social media but your report also says
that some communities in our country are
still
haunted by historic racism
what did you mean by that well
this is kind of speaking to the fact
many of uh
we know for a fact that people feel that
there are
there is significant racism in this
country
we can i can point to uh the the
official crime survey for england and
wales which shows actually racially
motivated crimes have gone down
massively over time but it
it's the case that it doesn't change
that people very much feel
that that that not reflective of their
reality and
what what that's uh speaking to is a
kind of a legacy because
of course britain was severely racist
a long time ago and there was
considerable racism
only you know four or five decades ago
and these are people who
there's many people living in the
country today who would have been
experiencing racism on a daily basis
and so yes there is a lot of people in
the country
who have will be living with that legacy
of feeling that you know britain's not
for them
um they perhaps won't have experienced
um
the kind of prosperity that many of the
younger generations
um have experienced so there is
definitely a legacy but you know
we've had kind of um people coming out
today
particularly on the left and kind of you
know these woke
activists and saying the report has
denied racism that's not the case
at all we have said in fact if they look
on just the first
recommendation the first recommendation
is to tackle
racist um language and to tackle kind of
racism and to empower the equality's
watchdog to do that
and on page 36 we actually set out a
kind of framework so that
we can properly kind of um disentangle
the different manifestations of racism
instead of just kind of
applying a blanket um accusation of
racism
on everything well anybody who thinks we
haven't come a long way didn't live
in our country in the 50s or 60s i
remember
a by-election campaign uh in a labor
seat in which
the uh i think it was the tory candidate
that i should be careful
the their election slogan was if you
want
n word for a neighbor then vote labor
so i think we've we're not there yet but
we've come a long way
from attitudes uh uh like like that
and when i when i look at your report it
seems
things are more complicated and more uh
uh
sophisticated more news rhys is uh
obviously a factor in some things but
family influence i think your report
says
social class culture religion and so on
are all
just as important and sometimes maybe
more important than race
is that correct yeah that's correct and
um you know what the fundamentally what
we're saying
is disparity is not always
discrimination
um in the same way that you know
everybody
knows or should know that um correlation
is not causation
so our approach was to
a kind of inductive approach we start
with the data
and then we kind of let the data lead us
and what the data showed
is that there are all these um other
factors and also that there are
disparities that really can't really be
explained by kind of this
white on um to use that dreaded term
racism one of the shocking things one of
the most shocking things for me
in the report was that uh black
young black people between age 16 to 24
are 24 times more likely to be victims
of homicide
than their white counterparts that is
for me
you know on a scandalous level um
you know to say okay well that must be
proof of racism well actually that
you're basically
kind of ignoring all the other variables
that might be driving that
clearly there's issues of deprivation
there's issues of
perhaps even absent fathers which i'm
sure you know people don't like to go
down that route
um there's all these issues that we
really could be talking about
um to tackle what is you know a shocking
statistic which is that you know 24
times more likely to be killed
um so these are the sorts of
conversations we should be having
and instead we get led down this path of
you know
a tit for tap you know conversation
about oh
is it institutional racism does it exist
does it not and then you get ridiculous
things as well from i saw clive lewis
the labor mp
his response uh to the report was to
tweet
an image of a kkk um person
so you know that kind of level of debate
is just i mean i would say it's
laughable but
it's not even funny at all i just don't
think the people who are criticizing
this report
um are have actually come out with
anything
to tell us why exactly what data they
disagree with
what recommendations they disagree with
and why so it's you know
again we're getting into a lot of
tit-for-tat identity politics stuff
instead of dealing with the real issues
but a final question to you you must
have known you were going to stir up a
hornet's nest here i mean
the current fashion on both sides of the
atlantic
uh and perhaps even a growing uh
fashion uh in anti-racism is to see
all ethnic disadvantage all ethnic
disadvantage
through the prism of white supremacy
and you're challenging that head-on so
it's quite a threat
to those who traditionally have seen
themselves
as the people who spoke up for racial
disadvantage
yes that's right and i think that is the
battle on our hands and
you know all these things like kind of i
mean one of the
i can never pronounce her surname but dr
scholler who's always kind of brought
out by mainstream channels to provide
commentary on race
you know her her response to the report
was to call dr tony sewell
um a token black man who was spreading
white supremacist lies
now tony saw is has dedicated his life
to
supporting ethnic minority people
fulfill their full potential he runs a
charity that helps
young black and ethnic minority kids go
into stem careers
to suggest he's spreading white
supremacist lies i mean that just shows
the level of detachment from reality and
actually
these people try to intimidate you into
being silent about
the days of being silent about all these
disparities and
um you know to to to coin a phrase i
won't be silent and i won't be silenced
andrew well they've had it their own way
for so long mercy
that you've now threatened them with
this report so i'm not surprised that
they're going to be
kicking back because their very purpose
of existing
is undermined by what your report says
messi thank you for joining us on
spectator tv i hope you
come back as this issue develops is not
going to go away and remember if you
enjoy
what we do here at spectator tv take out
a subscription
to the magazine itself is the fastest
growing current affairs publication in
europe within its pages
on our website you can read more from
all your favorite spectator
tv contributions and this week's
editorial which is
very much on what mercy and i were just
talking about there we'll even throw in
a bottle of free spectator
gin you just have to google spectatorgen
you can do that
that's a subscription of 12 issues for
just 12 quid
free bottle of gin worth 30 pounds it's
a no-brainer
now it wasn't that long ago that the
french teacher samuel patty was
executed by a lone islamist for showing
a cartoon of the prophet muhammad
that uh comparison hasn't prevented some
from protesting outside of
battley grammar school over the last few
weeks because a teacher there
had shown his pupils a caricature of
muhammad
as part of a class on blasphemy against
religions
now that teacher has since had to go
into hiding
sparking another debate about free
speech and religious respect
but faye as mughal disputes whether
these protesters
could really represent the muslim
community he's the founder of
tel mamma an organization which records
anti-muslim incidents in the uk
and he joins us now on the show father
welcome uh to spectator tv
you write that the protesters against
the teacher
are actually a defamation of islam what
do you mean by that
well essentially islam like any other
faith context
is a set of beliefs and
part of those beliefs are exceptionally
personal and they are based on tolerance
they are based
on a connection between individuals and
god and they are not based on
uh intimidation thuggery and
trying to force people to change their
opinions
that's a fundamental premise of one of
the beginnings of islam
is to talk to people is to listen and
dissent
was a fundamental part in the beginning
of islam and so
the this kind of twisting of islam into
using force uh intimidation
uh mob style tactics goes against the
very principle of the start of the faith
so it is a
perversion of what the core principles
are
and yet you also write that if you speak
up in favor
of the teachers say whether you're
muslim or non-muslim
either way if you do that you you'll
become a target of what you call
mob culture
absolutely we we live in a we live at a
time today where sadly social media and
other mechanisms provide an opportunity
for individuals to
vent their fury and their spleen and the
reality is
um sitting behind computer screens um
i know members of muslim communities who
have spoken up on other issues like this
who have talked about the need to listen
to dialogue and sometimes just to sit
and be uncomfortable listening to views
they might not like
being targeted being abused online
having letters sent to their employers
having campaigns
runs a local most stone include them in
their activities
and these kind of campaigns are
campaigns of intimidation
uh undermining that take place and so
individuals have been targeted i myself
have been targeted over seven years in
these kind of tactics
smear tactics and so it is a way to stop
those speaking out
who believe that this country's values
and
british muslim values actually are in
synergy are in tandem and there is very
little that separates us
but in in fact in earnest british islam
has been living
adapting shifting and changing
with the with the changing norms of this
country
as any other thought process does fayez
when did it become
because i don't think it's always been
like this when did it become so
provocative
so provocative that you could even lose
your life
to show an image of the prophet
so here's andrew it's fantastic
fantastic question because
because this problem is not just a 9 11
or 7
7 problem it's easy to have those
reference points because obviously
time is it's the nearest and closest
reference point to a major catastrophe
around
these kind of issues and where islam
became into the forefront of the news
topic and debates but this issue goes
back to the iranian revolution
it goes as far back as that and the
reality is if you
look at where a lot of muslim
communities were
internationally their developments their
dynamics
prior to the revolution you didn't have
a
sense of core muslim visibility and
identity
in most countries in countries like
egypt north africa middle east
there wasn't a sense of the islamic
identity being the
only primary identity that people
immediately responded to
what the islamic revolution in iran did
was to basically place
religion at the forefront of the
political ideology in the region
and it was exported across
into western uh spheres
and so the islamic revolution in iran
provided an
islamist identity which seemed to catch
fire
and in doing so also spread this notion
that actually anything around islam was
now
sacred and sacred to the point that
violence and intimidation could be used
and that was the starting point then
reinforced by the salman rushdie affair
of 1989 that salman rushdie affair
localized contextualized and placed that
sense of using intimidation and violence
within a british
context so these are two key reference
marker points
as to the start and genesis of what has
become
a blasphemy style tradition
in small sections but vocal and
intimidating sections of my
co-religionist today
and for those demonstrating outside
battle grammar
some appearance others are clearly
activists and troublemakers that want to
join the bandwagon
we've reached the stage though where as
you say violence is
is uh threatened because i see
you quoting your excellent article that
they're saying unless the government
stops this unless the government makes
sure
no other teacher even thinks of doing
this
the quote you give we are not
responsible for the actions
of some individuals if you don't do this
that's a threat
that's a threat that's a threat um so so
some of these
self-appointed community faith leaders
essentially have said and said to the
prime minister
can you believe it i mean the sheer
hutzpah
the sheer hotspot and the goal of this
telling the prime minister
that unless you force unless you bring
in and enforce some
some form of blasphemy there may be
some action i.e a threat
and an inference of threat there now the
reality is
those kind of statements should be
consigned to
as i said the dust spin not only the
dust in the dustbin of history
but should be ridiculed because to use
another threat
again in the process to tell the state
machinery
that the blasphemy law which was removed
in 2008 needs to be
reinforced is a is a gross
misunderstanding as i said in my article
of the history
of faith and its development in our
country but also in where we are today
and how
the wider society feels about religion
they don't want clearly never want any
form of blasphemy introduced we've got
rid of it it was repealed and it was a
nonsense act that was still around until
2008. so there's a lack of understanding
but there's this sense of there's a
sense that actually
some of these faith leaders think they
are entitled
to enforce their opinion as if islam is
so weak
that it can't withstand any critique
or ridicule which in itself shows an
infantile nature
that is projected onto british muslims
of which micro-religionists
are not final question to you i think
i would advise people to go and read
your article it's online in the
spectator website it's a fascinating
insight
too and i thank you for doing it for the
spectator
but i would conclude with this for your
reaction
everything you say i think most people
who read it they will agree with
but the hard reality is this it's over
for that teacher now
that teacher's life has been changed
forever uh
that teacher's family has been changed
forever
no one else is going to do this now
they're going to think really twice
about doing this when they've seen
what's happened to this teacher i know
salman rushdie i i was with simon
rushdie
a few years after the fatwa and i met
him for dinner in pimlico
there were four special branch
bodyguards with them
as i walked in i had to be searched and
so on but he's a rich man
he was able to disappear to new york and
he has reinvented his life in some ways
he's still with us
thank goodness uh and he doesn't need
quite so much security
but if you're just a school teacher none
of that's open
your life's been ruined by doing
something that you thought was
perfectly reasonable in teaching a class
about blasphemy
they've behaved in a way that you've
destroyed him
no one else is going to volunteer to do
the same they've won
there is a lot of truth in what you've
just said
the fact of the matter is this
individual is going to sadly
sadly and depressingly have to watch
their back for just trying to elicit
learning and teaching which was not
targeting let me be clear
a muslim student that would be
distinctly different this was about
conversation
understanding dialogue things that
people go to school to learn about
it wasn't about an attack on islam it
was about that dialogue
and this individual has lost their
profession and as you said will be
watching
their shoulder for the rest of their
life sadly
and that is as that is a sad indictment
of where we
are if today in 2021 we cannot defend
the core values of our country
and i end on saying this which are also
the fundamental core
values of islam the prophet
muhammad said muhammad has said
consistently
the pen is mightier than the sword
always said learn it's a fundamental
part of islam
the most sacred element is learning that
is the lesson that these uh
self-appointed leaders have lost
well yes we thank you for your article
and thank you for joining us on
spectator tv
and remember you can get 12 issues of
the spectator for just 12 pounds
you get a free bottle of spectator gin
with 30 pounds
now our final segment today what should
the west do about china
in many ways it seems like a new cold
war has begun but of course
china is a very different beast from the
soviet union
soviet union wasn't integrated into the
western economy the west did not depend
on soviet manufacturing indeed we didn't
really buy anything from the soviet
union at all the soviet union tried not
to buy
much from us now james forsythe has
written this week's leak feature on the
importance of an economic alliance
against china uh he's still with us on
the show and also with us
i'm delighted we're joined by the ft's
gideon rachman he's author of
easternization war and peace in the
asian century
which of course he refers to as the 21st
century
james let me come to you first then i'll
go straight to uh gideon who's been
waiting patiently there
are we in a new cold war is a cold war
the right way to see
the right prism for what is happening
with china and the rest
i think you can debate the precise
historical parallel i know you could
argue it's like the rise of germany from
kind of 1870 to 1914
onwards or you can say it is like the
the cold war i think i think that the
point is
that there there is now you know history
is back
in that there is now a values contest
you are we are now in a situation where
the democratic world is faced by
a china that that wishes not to rise
peacefully not to hide and bide as
danger ping talked about
but to actively change the global order
you know and it's quite explicit that by
2049 it wishes to be the most powerful
economic and military
power on earth and to have a global
system that reflects that
and i think that the west now faces a
massive moment which is
has it got the strategic ability to come
together
to contain this challenge i think there
is still time
for a unified western effort to push
back on china
but but that time is running short and
it won't work
if the west is divided gideon what do
you say to that
yeah and i think that in current
circumstances uh it's unlikely that the
west will muster the unity required to
create this kind of
economic nato that james is talking
about there are divisions between
the european union and the united states
there are many western companies
that are deeply integrated in the
chinese economy i mean for a company
like
forks of argon or daimler-benz china's
now their biggest
market their biggest single export
market um
and so they're big sacrifices to make
but i think the caveat
is that the chinese may do it for us in
the sense that if their
activities and um become
so outrageous from our viewpoint that
they can no longer be tolerated they may
sort of force a change in western policy
that we're quite reluctant to consider
at the moment i mean
their policies in xinjiang have
obviously caused a huge backlash
and then china-imposing sanctions
but you know if they were for example to
assault taiwan and you know they're on
the front page of
the ft website at the moment there's
speculation which is
so rather of spine chilling that they
may actually be
contemplating an attack on taiwan at
that point all bets are off
you know i cannot see that that you
couldn't have comprehensive sanctions
against china if that were to happen
in the current circumstances though i
think the the mood is shifting against
china but there are these enormous
economic interests at stake
which won't be easily untangled what is
in your view the
the the goal of child what's the
strategic
geopolitical glow goal at the height of
the the cold war
many people thought what we were
confronting was soviet
global domination of spreading communism
across the world now some people
argue that wasn't the case but that was
the basis of western foreign policy
james has said the chinese want to be
the dominant economy
but are they exporting an ideology like
the russians
like the soviets or or is it more just
they want the world
more to be organized in ways conducive
to them
i think more the latter i mean i would
guess you know and obviously it's a big
place you know it's
1.4 billion people and even within the
communist party there will be arguments
and debates that we're not
fully cognizant of but i think xi
jinping is pretty firmly
in charge at the moment and from what he
says um
you know they've got a number of goals i
think his first goal is simply to secure
himself in power
but that has an external aspect because
the way that he discusses it
is this belief that the west is trying
to ferment color revolutions in china
it's trying to overthrow the communist
party and that is regarded
as you know a direct threat to him and
to the system he's building
but he's also talked about china moving
closer to the global
center stage uh and i think that that
resonates you know as it would for many
countries there's this
feeling that for china's had a couple of
bad centuries but has
thousands of years of history that
historically it has been the middle
kingdom
and that it would be its natural um
destiny if you like as it becomes more
powerful and richer
to become the dominant power at least in
asia
but that is not nothing because the
united
states is the dominant power in in the
in the pacific region at the moment and
if china is
to displace it in a sense with the asian
economy now the core of the global
economy
china by becoming the regional hegemon
becomes pretty close to the dominant
power in the world
the americans though i think gideon have
realized that as they
deal with the rise of china uh it's a
very different animal from the soviet
union the soviet union had great
military power
but in terms of its economy or its
technology
it was nowhere near a match i remember
the first time i went to moscow and our
sunday times moscow correspondent said
we stood in red square and she said
welcome
to the evil empire it was in the reagan
age it's really just
upper volta with missiles that's not
china
and i think am i right gideon that the
the americans have realized that if they
are to counter
the rise or at least control the rise
of china in the greater pacific region
they
need allies even they are not big enough
to do it on their own absolutely and i
think that they
they're having the americans are having
an interesting and
open debate about you know if they went
to war with china god forbid who would
win
uh so admiral phil davidson who is uh
you know the indo-pacific command i
think he may just be about to step down
but he
testified in congress that in in five or
six years time
there would be no guarantee that the
united states would prevail in a
conflict
over taiwan for example you know america
is very very heavily invested in
aircraft carriers but china's been
building up
carrier killer missiles for a very long
time it has more submarines
it actually has a larger navy than the
united states although smaller in terms
of tonnage more ships
and taiwan's next door to them and for
them it's an existential issue they
would definitely fight over it
there is a question mark of whether the
united states would fight over it and
those kinds of uncertainties are are
dangerous because if you have
absolute certainty that were there a
conflict the u.s would prevail there's
less likely to be a conflict but you
know in in the current situation
both sides could could miscalculate and
i think on the the question of
technology that you mentioned it's very
i think the americans have been shaken
as you say by the technological prowess
of the united of china
i mean you know swapping anecdotes you
said you were in red square i mean i
when i was in beijing three or four
years ago visiting a family member who
was
studying there uh you suddenly struck
that
the airport at beijing is just much
smarter than jfk
that uh you know that as we were walking
down the road she was able to buy
food with her phone just by holding it
up to a street store you can't do
you couldn't do that in the west at the
moment so you know they were ahead on
certain technologies
and on 5g which has been the big thing
where
america has really essentially twisted
britain's arm not to take
chinese 5g technology one of their
problems is there isn't a us 5g at the
moment
so china china is ahead on many key
technologies
james one of the things i was struck by
in your article was though that you you
thought
that china may have um played its cards
too quickly
moved too soon uh
so that it may indeed have undermined
its own deal that it wants to have with
the eu
or on investment that it's it's cracked
down in hong kong
before it's got all its ducks in a row
the same with the uyghurs and the uh
essentially labor camps concentration
camps pretty close
that that it it's simply overplayed
and has given america and its allies
some time to get their act together
james yeah i think as as gideon was
saying
to you earlier andrew they have
miscalculated in that they are making
things very difficult for the west to
ignore i mean since
she came to power they have become more
assertive and especially since
covid they have become much more
aggressive and i think if you look at
their response to these sanctions i
think you see how this nationalist
impulse to always hit back harder
which president xi particularly
encourages this kind of so-called wolf
warrior diplomacy
is flawed because the issue on which the
west finds it
easiest to unify around china isn't the
economic questions that you and gideon
were talking about but it
is obviously the question of human
rights in xinjiang
the issue of the way that the uyghur
muslims have been treated the west
got its act together coordinated western
action from you know the eu the u.s
canada and the uk to sanction for a
handful of chinese officials
over this internment programme if the
chinese have kind of ignored that
i think that you know things that have
carried on this eu china investment
treaty would have gone through
instead they chose to hit back the
sanctions they've sanctioned five meps
from four of the different groupings in
the european parliament
that i think makes it really now quite
unlikely the eu china investment treaty
fails
and if that treaty fails to be ratified
that will i think
sour eu china relations and makes it
more likely
that uh the biden administration will
have a chance to craft a more unified
western economic response to china if
the
game of american policy james is to
build a countervailing alliance to
the inevitable rise of china that can't
be stopped
but you could have some countervailing
power to to stop it getting out of hand
in a long list of potential candidates
what was mr trump's decision to pull out
of the
pacific trade partnership not one of the
most stupid decisions of his
four years in the white house yeah i
mean i think his historians might well
look back and say that that was
among the worst if not the worst i think
you see america trying to
get back into the region you look at
this very interesting initiative where
the quad
which is uh the the us
japan india and australia they're
coordinating on vaccines
with the us and japan paying for india
to make them and australia to distribute
them
in an attempt to kind of counter some of
china's influence in the region
now biden has been very reluctant
essentially to do anything on trade
before uh the midterm elections but i
think
you're right andrew if the us is serious
about
uh countering china it is gonna have to
i think
join and bolster tpp and to build up a
kind of
coalition of the willing on trade that
acts as an alternative i think
one of the changes we might have to
adjust to in the west is that china's
power and influence in global
institutions now
means that you know reforming the wto
along the lines that the west would like
removing china's developing nation
status and like might well be impossible
and in the same way that at the
beginning of a cold war you know you
formed gas
you know the the western democratic
nations might have to do something
similar on
trade um and tpp is the is the obvious
kind of building block for that can you
let me come to you finally
if i was sitting in washington i look at
europe and i see that
russia is basically a regional threat if
it's a threat at all russia is a
regional threat
to what it regards as the near abroad
and in
europe that is what we used to call
eastern europe i've also got all these
european allies and they're really
really
really reluctant to spend money on
defense
i'm having to do most of it indeed i've
got chancellor merkel
in germany actually doing a deal to buy
russian gas
i look over the pacific where i've got
my other big problem china which is a
much bigger problem than russia
but hey there i've got allies i've got
allies there that
are actually realize that china's a
threat
and they're prepared to spend money on
defense a lot of money
on defense that would give me some hope
would that be right
well to a degree but i think in some
ways it's more complicated because if
you look at japan which is the key power
you know the japanese constitution
massively constricts the ability of the
japanese to fight
uh you know much more actually than than
even the germans
and that's a problem um and uh
you know south korea is in a very tricky
situation has a relatively left-wing
government
um so it's true that america has a
network of alliances
in asia as well as in europe but i think
they pose they're both problematic in
different ways that
they're definitely assets you know china
has no allies it has one formal
treaty ally which is north korea it's
probably one you don't want um
but these alliances are are
difficult because allies have their own
views and their own domestic politics
um but but they're they're they're
undoubtedly an american asset
i mean i think that the implication of
your question that they're going to
switch attention increasingly to the
asia pacific
is the case uh you know obama was
talking about a pivot to asia
uh trump spent more time in asia than
than he did in europe i think that the
main difference
is that trump regarded the europeans
as drones as you know almost adversaries
at times i think that the
biden administration although they will
share many of the same irritations about
low european defense spending
have come to the sort of intellectual
realization that if they have any chance
of coordinating a pushback against china
they have to have
the european democracies on their side
and they're going to do their utmost to
to organize that
all right gideon rachman from the
financial times thank you for being with
us on spectator
tv today and james forsyth of the
spectator thank you
as well that's it for this week thanks
to all of our guests and once again to
our very special sponsor
charles stanley for sponsoring the week
in 60 minutes
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms
one of the oldest firms on the london
stock exchange a final reminder to pick
up that bottle of spectator gin you mean
you need after some of our
conversations it's worth 30 pounds it's
all yours for free if you sign up to the
spectator at spectator dot co dot uk
slash tv offer you can just google
spectator gin the spectator
is now got a record 100 000 plus
subscribers so why not join the winning
team
please send us your thoughts to
spectator tv at spectator dot co dot uk
i hope you can join us again next week
have a very happy easter
and bye bye
[Music]
you